und damit einen wunderschönen guten
Mittag aus kosamui ich weiß ich sehe
sehr amüsant aus hier mit meinem Helm
und meinem Monster Energy
rollerschlüssel das ist der Schlüssel
für unseren Roller den haben wir jetzt
seit zwei Tagen heute steht was cooles
auf dem Programm und zwar ziehen wir um
ich habe jetzt gerade hier meine Sachen
geparkt wir sind hier gerade beim
Christoph auch ein deutscher den kenne
ich schon länger habe ich damals
kennengelernt vor z D Jahren und der
wohnt halt hier auf kosamui hat ja auch
so ein kleines Häuschen und hier haben
wir gerade unsere Sachen untergestellt
aber jetzt geht's weiter can see Henning
and
Christop how are you guys wie geht
genau wir ziehen heute nämlich in ein
wirklich richtig geiles Haus ich habe
mir gedacht das muss ich einmal machen
wenn ich jetzt schon hier bin weil hier
auf kusamui gibt es halt ziemlich viele
Mountains bin schon so wie jemand der
irgendwie dii Wochen in Australien war
und dann immer diese dummen Wörter
einbaut hier gibt ziemlich viele hohe
Berge und dort gibt es halt Willen die
reingebaut wurden und das Interessante
ist bei den meisten Willen hat man halt
auch ein privaten Koch dabei und auch
Leute die dort arbeiten und die halt
quasi dann für einen zuständig sind das
klingt total dumm und würde ich auch
niemals Prat machen nur ich dachte mir
wenn ich jetzt hier bin Thailand ist ja
relativ günstig günstiger bekomme ich
sowas nicht mache ich mir doch mit
Henning hier drei entspannte letzte Tage
weil am Mittwoch also wir pennen da drei
Nächte geht's dann weiter auf die
nächste Insel und ich dachte mir mache
ich ein Blog zu wir schauen mal wie das
wird ich muss sagen ein bisschen
skeptisch bin ich weil die Kommunikation
lief nicht ganz so gut ich bin jetzt in
irgendwie so einer whatsappgruppe da
sind sechs Leute drin und ich und die
warten jetzt auf uns ich bin mal
gespannt Leute let's go das hier ist das
motorbike vom Christoph und das hier ist
unserer okay ich wä soweit ja geil so
wir fahren jetzt hier um die Kurve an
der Küste lang und dann geht's hier hoch
und dann ja sind wir da Rollerfahren ist
hier wirklich deutlich gefährlicher als
in Deutschland die fahren h wie die
besenken deswegen immer schön aufpassen
das hier ist die Einfahrt zu Christop
finde ich sehr entspannend also ist was
anderes ne wir sind so ein paar Hühner
auf dem auf
[Musik]
Weg auch interessant alle ohne Helm also
und hier fahren auch Kinder der deutsche
Führerschein ist ja auch nicht anerkannt
aber es interessiert e kein ob du ein
hast oder nicht also mit anderen Worten
wir sind hier nicht versichert ja genau
aber das kärt man hier auch unter der
[Musik]
Hand wir fahen jetzt hier den Berg hoch
da oben könnt ihr vielleicht schon paar
Häuser sehen und irgendeins davon ist
das dann ja K
[Musik]
noch ja der alex hat so eben in unserer
Luxus Garage geparkt das Ding ist Hal
einfach das ist so Thailand auf Fotos
sieht richtig geil aus und die Bewertung
war auch nur so semi deswegen habe ich
mich auch darauf eingestellt dass wir
jetzt nicht hier in der krass im
krassesten Haus ankommen
D Hal so voll viele Menge gibt aber
alles
gut wir sind auf jeden Fall jetzt
angekommen hier und gucken uns das Ding
mal an
ne
[Musik]
okay niemand von uns nur zwe ja die
Aussicht ist echt
klasse
okay Leute ich jetzted meine grße
rausholen also
das
bisschenier und auf nchsten di Tage zu
verbringen schaut euch mal diese
gewaltig geile Aussicht an man kann halt
nicht nur rechts das Meer sehen sondern
auch noch Links da vorne ist noch ein
see also was Landschaft und Aussicht
angeht ist das hier wirklich ganz ganz
großes Kino ich glaube hier waren wir
gerade schon drin als wir die Führung
bekommen haben das ist jetzt mein Zimmer
ist natürlich auch mega geil also vorem
auf der Kamera wird's rüberkmen als wä
es unfassbar geil ist es auch keine
Frage vor allem hier noch mit den Stein
dann haben wir diese Badewanne und dazu
dann diesen geilen Ausblick ach so ein
Balkon ist ja auch wie dabei
ja schon krass hier sind halt ziemlich
viele Häuser nebenan auch und es ist
ziemlich hellhörig und worauf ich mich
schon eingestellt habe was aber auf der
Kamera wirklich überhaupt nicht
rüberkomt wird denke ich in Thailand
immer dieser Unterschied wie sieht's auf
Fotos aus wie ist es im echt also auf
Fotos wirklich genial richtig geiles
teil und das ist es auch keine Frage nur
ich sag mal wenn man in europäischen
Ländern sowas mietet es fängt schon an
bei der Dusche die ist z.B schief hier
könnt ihr auch sehen es ist überall
dreckig hier ist sogar halt ja ein
bisschen mich stört das nicht aber ich
will es euch ja natürlich zeigen und
nicht vorhalten also ich weiß nicht was
mit dem Spiegel los ist aber der ist
halt komplett hier so abgeranzt das hier
ist total wackelig und man denkt man
fällt hier gleich runter aber es kostet
eben auch nur und ja ich weiß es ist
trotzdem viel zu viel 450 € pro Nacht
mit Koch der Frühstück macht der abends
was macht es wird einem laut also so wie
es da steht jeder Wunsch von den Lippen
abgelesen ich muss einfach in die
whatsappgruppe schreiben und dann macht
das jemand der Koch und die Mitarbeiter
wohnen neben an in so einem Haus also
nicht hier bei uns also ich bin auf
jeden Fall mal gespannt auf die nächsten
Tage hier und ich freue mich schon hier
wird Henning schlafen der freut sich
auch ist ja schon auch was besonderes so
so eine geile Aussicht hier habe ich
auch jetzt erst zum zweiten Mal in
meinem Leben dass es so krass aussieht
aber ja h kann man aushalten chr ist
gerade auch noch hier was sagst du als
kosamui Bewohner zu diesem Haus also ich
fin es klasse eigentlich aber irgendwie
die Getränke fehlen die getränkeeh die
eiskalten Getränke meine geliebte
eiskalte Cola ist nicht da das stimmt
kleiner Abzug in der bnote ansonsten ich
sag mal vergleichsweise mit anderen
Häusern du warst ja schon sicherlich auf
ein paar Häusern Aussicht ist genial gar
kein Thema ist mega und der Rest ist für
thailändische Verhälnisse auch
eigentlich richtig klasse sind so ein
paar Schönheitsfehler aber ja gut da
kannst du mal weg gucken aber so ist
mega okay so so sieht übrigens der
Kühlschrank aus die Getränke sind auch
mit dabei immer wenn wir was brauchen
sollen wir bescheid sagen wir haben
einmal schangbier das ist eigentlich das
leckerste Bier hier Cola Zero und hier
normale Cola und das hier ist noch eine
Weinflasche was wollt ihr
trinken
und damit einen
wunderschönen guten Morgen Leute kann
man aufstehen wir Glück haben wir das
Frühstück schon
[Musik]
gemacht
so morgen morgen erstmal schwim gehen
[Musik]
ist gar nicht
tief wan MS wir morgench mal aufstehen
oh müssen 7:15 Uhr ganz unten am Hill so
jetzt bin ich auf jeden Fall wach willst
du ja so so kann man noch wach werden so
Frühstück ist auf jeden fall in the
making ich zeig's euch
mal wem gehört denn das da ja ich trink
mein Weinglas immer leer so Leute
frühstück ist fertig wir haben uns hier
für das English Breakfast entschieden so
kann man auf jeden Fall wach werden also
ich glaube ich bin selten also
eigentlich ja noch nie mit so tollen
Ausblick und dann auch noch som tollen
Service morgens man muss Hal eigentlich
gar nichts machen das ist schon klasse
ne hen guten appetik guten Alex nur was
den Kaffee angeht da muss man hier ein
Thailand man für abstrche machen warte
mal eigentlich habe ich auch Pancakes
bestellt sind das Pancakes ach so ich
dachte das wären auch Eier das sind aber
riesen
Pancakes so Leute ich war jetzt gerade
noch in der Stadt ein paar Besorgung
machen und hinter uns wird jetzt schon
das Abendessen vorbereitet heute ganz
besonders also irgendwie weiß ich gar
nicht ob ich das mag aber es ich habe es
auch noch nie in meinem Leben gegessen
es gibt auf jeden Fall Hummer Christop
kommt gleich auch noch vorbei und dann
werden wir hier draußen essen ich bin
mal gespannt es sieht jetzt so aus hier
Sonne ist schon untergegangen dunkel
geworden wir haben jetzt hier draußen
den Tisch gedeckt
und ja ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen
verstört von dem was sie da drin machen
weil da also das ist hier zwar völlig
normal weiß ich ja auch aber der R der
lebt noch na nicht mehr lange al ganzen
Tag Fischen
und hast irgendwie
gewi ganz wenn meine vegane Community
die werden mich killen
dafür ja doch ich probi das
so hier wird schon mal Reis vorbereitet
very ja ja
[Musik]
okay so der Tisch füllt sich so langsam
wir haben jetzt hier schon die Krappen
und hier haben wir glaube ich Papaya
Salat paar Soßen sieh doch klasse aus
Christ already hungry hungry hungry hung
ich habe ganzen Tag extra gegessen weil
ich wusste was Du hier aufch super das
Essen richtet Leute muss wirklich sagen
also die beiden Köchen echt allererste
Sahne was sie da gezaubert haben das sah
schon echt professionell aus thank you
also wir haben jetzt auf jeden Fall hier
Papaya Salat Christoff ist das ne
papayaasalat ja typisch thailändisch som
ne dann haben wir hier noch
Riesengarnelen Reis mit ein paar
vegetables drin scharfe Soße süße Soße
Tintenfisch hier ist noch der
Tintenfisch und die Hummer kommen gleich
noch mein Gott ey was haben wir denn
hier alles da kann man ja wirklich nicht
meckern ne ja ja kurzer
reistest kurze der reisprobe sehr boah
super lecker hier haben wir jetzt die
Riesengarnelen da macht man erstmal den
Kopf ab ne Kopf ab oh thank you so much
thank you muss aber eins Bedenken die
Thailänder die werden sich jetzt schwarz
ärgern weil der Kopf ist eigentlich auch
eine Delikatesse
ne amazing
gut ich glaube ich probi mal den Papaya
Salat was ist das noch mal also
papayasalat ist ja Papaya kennen wir bei
uns ist die rote süße Frucht aber hier
wird die unreif geerntet sozusagen m und
dann ist es diese grüne Papaya die wird
klein gehackt D bisschen Mörchen
bisschen Boden dabei dann kommen da
natürlich Tomaten rein und jede Menge
Chili natürlich also müsste richtig Piff
haben spicy hier PAP spicy die haben nur
eine Chili reingemacht extra für Dich
sonst kommen da sechs rein also
irgendwas in diesem Essen killt mich
gerade es ist so scharf oh
Lobster
Alter
thank also so sieht jetzt auch nicht
jedes Dinner hier aus das ist was ganz
besonderes ich wusste auch bis vor
meinem Thailand Urlaub gar nicht dass
ich sowas eigentlich mag ich probiere
zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben
Hummer ich habe so ein Ding auch noch
nie vorher gegessen thank you thank you
man muss ja auch sagen Hummer ist schon
teuer ne also in Europa ich habe keine
Ahnung davon aber das ist schon teures
Essen ne ja also nicht nur in Europa
hier kostet da natürlich auch richtig
Geld also wer 50 € kostet einer ja nee
noch mehr das Kilo
100 € das Kilo 100 € ja ja hier und hier
wiegt einer so um die 760 g das ist ja
wie kurberint fast mal Daumen fast fast
an die 200 wir fliegen übrigens nach
Japan weiter da wollte ich das mal
probieren istst man den so oder mit der
Soße hier mit der süß sauersoße oder
curryoße
curße der war ja
schon vor zi Jahren hätte ich mir
niemals vorstellen können dass ich ir
mal Fisch mag also schon was besonderes
schmeckt guten morning Leute bin gerade
bei mir hier oben auf dem Balkon so
sieht's aus wenn die Sonne
aufgeht ich habe eigentlich gedacht sie
geht hier auf aber sie geht da auf
schade eigentlich also da ist halt der
Berg vor aber si trotzdem ganz cool aus
wir machen jetzt nämlich ein
Tagesausflug es ist gerade
6:30r wir werden jetzt hier
abgeholt da jetzt lang hier rechts
runter schaffen wir
das Okay Leute kurzes Zwischenfazit wir
sind jetzt mittlerweile schon eine Insel
weiter und zwar sind wir hier auf kotao
eigentlich wollte ich das Ende von dem
Video bei uns am Hotel Filmen nur die
Sonne geht hier gerade unter und ich
finde das sieht so geil aus wir sind
hier gerade auf jeden Fall einer
ziemlich coolen Bucht sieht echt sehr
schön aus hier kann man auch super
Schnorcheln auf jeden Fall verbringen
wir jetzt noch drei Tage und dann machen
wir uns wieder auf den Weg zum feststand
weil für uns geht's ja noch weiter nach
Japan am Ende natürlich noch ein kurzes
Fahrzeit zum Haus ich muss sagen wir
haben da ja insgesamt drei Nächte
übernachtet ihr habt nur so die
Highlights gesehen es war schon
entspannt dass immer jemand da war der
sich um alles gekümmert hat wir hatten
immer essen man konnte halt einfach die
Zeit genießen und diese phänomenale
Aussicht auch ich will es aber nicht
normal machen das war echt zu viel Geld
hier z.B schlafen wir jetzt für 70 € die
Nacht in ein wirklich vernünftigen Hotel
direkt am Strand und das lohnt sich
eigentlich sogar mehr finde ich wenn man
hier dieses Strandfeeling hat trotzdem
waren es entspannte drei letzte Tage auf
kosamui ich hoffe dir hat auch gefallen
hen super und wenn wir jetzt schon mal
dabei sind ich will euch auch unseren
Strand hier nicht vorenthalten so sieht
das aus also ich glaube ich habe noch
nie so einen krassen Sonnenuntergang
gesehen irgendwo also das ist hier
wirklich völlig verrückt genau hier ist
direkt so eine chillige Bar und dahinter
ist unser Hotel noch eine lustige Story
aus kosamui ich hat mein ganzes
Equipment in diesem safe drin der bei
mir im Zimmer war und der Safe einfach
kaputt dann haben die den aufgebrochen
und die meinten einfach zu mir es könnte
passieren dass der so leicht explodiert
ich dachte so das kann doch nicht wahr
sein wenn jetzt meine Kamera und alles
kaputt geht das wäre ziemlich schlecht
gewesen dann hätte ich nur noch mit
meinem iPhone filmen können und ich habe
echt noch richtig viel vor jetzt die
nächsten zwei Wochen deswegen gut dass
das nicht passiert ist ich blende euch
gerne hier noch mal ein Foto ein und ja
wir sehen uns in drei Tagen wieder ciao